here's a gentleman right here one of the
hard-working frontline workers out there
what's up do
what's up Brendan I got a debate club
for you FedEx or UPS you want that
purple and black hitter or that dirty
brown [ __ ] hey gang buzz buzz gang
brah I like what can Brown do for you
you feel me oh yeah when that brown UPS
truck shows up you know you got a nice
fresh package waiting there's nothing
like it man
I love UPS I know UPS has good programs
long term for the people that work over
there I think they got good severance
deals and all of that you know in
residual effects financially but I like
FedEx because I always thought FedEx
should open up a human South African the
later human trafficking not trafficking
but dealing yeah well that's what I'm
doing like an airline yeah no I'm great
way to be to fly FedEx because here's
the thing sometimes we be like oh your
planes been canceled we can't get you
there for two days you'll be at the
airport but FedEx you could walk across
the street to FedEx and Mail something
and it'll be there the next mission
overnight a package and I just take
FedEx why can't I fly with my package
yeah I'll hold it yeah let's hold it
just put me on the [ __ ] FedEx place
[Music]
this delivery beef damn I did I'll tell
you what though those UPS guys look like
[ __ ] dressed like y'all brown with
their short shorts and their hats and
[ __ ] you got a rep you set a really set
that's a good point and if it look dude
have you ever seen an alligator they are
afraid of the UPS guys but they are not
afraid of the FedEx dudes man
cuz of that outfit I think that they get
that Steve Irwin style just a darker
Brown yeah so it's more savage you know
I would love to see you guys fight I
would like to watch you guys fight yeah
I think they should set up some sort of
tough man contest with UPS and FedEx
they do it with cops and firefighters
mm-hmm I'm trying to watch my UPS guy
[ __ ] some people up yeah I wouldn't mind
seeing that man that'd be nice we're
building a whole car here FedEx for CPS
Chappelle versed
Johnny Curtis yeah you were
someone last episode last week is so
long ago I don't remember was it Gianni
it was Johnny no last week Boosie also
in its five rounds it's get knocked out
five times to be out I know Theo was
gonna fight Connor at 45 oh yeah with
that cocaine that's a yeah you have
cocaine in your face oh definitely I see
that's a damaged or if it's just you
versus Connor straight up you're gonna
lose deal on cocaine I like my eyes yeah
two grams of blow dude I'm taking on
duty I might lose but I'll definitely
take them on to Connors legs home with
me mm-hmm
I'll chew it off at the hip dude okay
I'll chew that fricking Irish [ __ ] off
[Music]